Oh two simple letters that marks one of
the biggest changes in human history in
1969 programmers were trying to type
login charlie typed the L he typed the o
he typed the G to get the G Wakko the
system crashed so the very first message
on the internet ever was low as in lo
and behold fifty years later and half
the world is now online but that half is
primarily from the rich world which
means that the other half quite
obviously will have to come from the
poor world how will the second half of
humanity coming online change the
internet and how will the internet
change them the really interesting place
to look at is India India's internet
penetration was pretty low until very
recently with the launch of a new mobile
network called Reliance Geo with
incredibly cheap phones and credibly
cheap data process Reliance Geo launched
aggressively in 2016
offering subsidised handsets and free
data to hook people in India went from
being a relatively expensive place to
consume data to being the cheapest in
the world prices crashed by 94% new
users in the developing world are
browsing the internet in much the same
way as people in the developed world
when people get online the first thing
they do is they Chocula friends they
watch sports they watch movies they
watch music videos or watch a extremely
large amount of pornography but this is
where the similarities end the internet
was built on the assumptions that many
users speak English are literate and a
media savvy none of those things
remain true for the second half of the
Internet
you have a whole bunch of languages that
don't enjoy very good support in terms
of web browsers or input and you have a
whole bunch of people who can't actually
read or write there's practically no
usage of desktop computers laptop
computers it's almost entirely on mobile
phones and these mobile phones tend not
to be the expensive very powerful ones
they have limited amounts of storage
this is prompting big tech companies to
change the way their products work
they're having to understand these new
behaviors they're having to
fundamentally rethink how they would
supply their services for much of the
world that is now coming online text is
not the natural way to interact it's
smaller apps that can do more and and
that can be used with voice or video
rather than text many tech giants have
already begun to establish themselves in
emerging markets Facebook has over 1.5
billion users in developing countries
and the YouTube channel with the most
subscribers is a Bollywood studio and
record label creating large user bases
is one thing making money from Lamy is
another the prevailing assumption around
making money on the internet on to this
point has been a largely American
assumption of advertising 99% of
Facebook's revenue comes from
advertising as there's 85% of Google's
but many people in the developing world
are poor so users don't have the same
value to advertisers take Facebook's
last quarter of 2018
they make twelve times as much money for
user in North America than they do in
Asia an overall annual revenue from the
developing world is much lower to Google
for instance about 46% of their revenues
come from the US alone and only about
15% from Asia that 15% includes rich
countries like Australia and Japan take
those away and the revenue from Asia
would be even lower
if the traditional advertising model
isn't going to work
tech companies will have to think
outside the box what people will pay for
is the opportunity to express themselves
until the advent of smartphones really a
big money spinner for Indian mobile
networks with something called a follow
really back Tony I would pick a song
that I like very much and if you were
calling me you would hear it do not pay
a monthly fee for that to happen now
think about exactly what this is I am
paying money for song I will never
listen to only so that I can so that my
friends were calling me I can hear it
because I want to express myself so
it'll be lots of novel ideas like that
for very very small amounts of money but
we're talking about lots and lots of
people doing these things one thing is
for sure the Internet's second
revolution will change people's lives
for the better the ability of people
around the world to have a good time is
becoming a little bit more equal and
that while hard to pin down in economic
data is a net benefit to just the
general well-being of humankind which
can be very easy to understate or to
ignore especially if you are used to
those things but has a really meaningful
impact